Hello, The Internet, we are here with,
all right, Dan, be there.
All right, Yeah, good thanks.
I've just started without you there.
Ignored me there, hi Internet.
Dan says hi, and so do I.
Now we're going to do a video
about little droplets of water,
that land right on the
surface of the water.
They're not going to come from high up.
They're just going to tip on
and we're going to see if
the droplet kind of bounces
on the surface and then
half goes in the water
and then bounces up and
then half goes and again,
until it's a really tiny little blob.
What are you on about?
Yeah did you not think that up?
That has never happened, ever.
It's complete crap.
We'll try it.
I don't know what you're on about.
So for this set up, I'm
using a macro lens, 105 mil
and Phantom flex.
If you can hold the drop?
I can do.
And I'll let you know
exactly where to let it go.
Try and get it just to
bounce on the surface.
Okay, yeah, I see what you're saying.
Oh, almost had it .
How's that?
Yeah, nailed it.
There you go.
Okay, watch that.
It already looks cool.
Ah amazing!
That is cool, there's a little,
little bubble that bounces off the big one
and then goes straight into it again.
That is really cool.
I didn't know that happened at all.
Yeah, it kind of, it
lets half the water in
and then it detaches and
bounces and then happens again
until there's bugger all left of it.
Yeah.
Is it all gone now?
No, still, it's just a
really small one though.
Oh, that is so cool, I
never knew that happened.
You didn't know that did that?
No, the mirror effect really cool as well.
It looks like someone's
throwing a little ball
that gets littler every time.
It's like, oh, I have a smaller one, boop.
They've given it to a kid
and by the time it's finished with it,
it's not there anymore.
Bloody told you no, didn't I?
There you go, proof.
Bet you feel like a right mug.
I was going to make a mug joke
but that is in fact not a mug.
No, it looks like a mug.
I was thinking the same thing.
Yeah, you're all right.
Oh, come on, there's no need.
I'm a bad loser, alright?
Yeah, yeah, all right.
Well, hope you enjoyed that, Internet.
I did.
Dan's already trying to get out of here.
So we'll see you in the next video, top.